[Music]
did you guys know
that in kuwait
you can have a pet
tiger
or lion you can have pet humans too
oh [ __ ]
yeah the middle east they're notorious
for that [ __ ] thanks mr jabberwocky
giving you the japanese
he's giving you the jab effects
jabba
jabba facts so you can just own a line
like you have a dog is it that simple
though like yeah
why are we surprised when we see middle
eastern like dudes with [ __ ] straight
up tigers and lamborghinis yeah that's
true like are we being racist when they
when we say like
you know there's a lot of instagrams out
there with middle eastern guys and just
like the robe attire
and then they have like a [ __ ] lion
and a tiger and they're rolling around
with them and then they get into their
lamborghini and then the tiger's head
comes out of the [ __ ] moon roof and
then they drive around town but i think
i only heard like two words
honestly just terrified right now you
guys can't hear anything no it just it
just i heard tiger it's like leather
fish
tiger
[Applause]
it's like michael myers is going to vote
that's why kenny sounds the way he does
on [ __ ]
[Laughter]
okay so check this out so there's they
actually have security camera footage of
a woman that's why jabba walkies don't
talk huh oh yeah that's why it's what
they think the mouthful is not big
enough you know they give their speeches
with dance
okay so check this out that's why they
don't talk you guys really don't [ __ ]
hear me no i'm not really
[Laughter]
she's pissed dude you ever had a pissed
chick just trying to take you out of a
party or something like that
holy [ __ ] that [ __ ] was going like a
[ __ ] wiggly cat dude like she's
[ __ ] brave they must have they're
clearly not trying to attack her yeah do
they have a prior relationship or yeah
that's probably their pet but it's
probably
everything's like neutralized they
probably just like [ __ ] file them
down or something like that because i
always bleed with my cat's claws but
they'll never like try and bite me or
anything like that you know what i mean
because they know you're cool because
and then cubs are nice like that's why
they they they have them at the petting
like places
environmental police in kuwait said that
the lion belongs to the woman and her
father oh i see they helped capture the
big cat when it was spotted wandering
the streets and it was returned to her
it was a loose cat it was a rescue it
got out or or it was trying to escape
yeah it got out back to its own head
what
[Music]
so yeah that's that's it
all right
guys 100 hit boys 2022
jk news is all about being
equal right
so when you put on whatever hat you got
to represent the views of each side
exactly extremely the question is
how do you feel about
pet
lions i say you should be able to own a
pet lion no matter where you live which
hat get the government out of my life
and off of my body
government out of your life wait is that
though
government out of my life
because there seems to be quite a few uh
with the joe biden hat wares trying to
tell people what to do with their life
right now
don't you think yeah isn't that but
isn't this like more government this is
more government not so fast because
there seems to be a lot of trump people
who like to tell women what to do with
their bodies oh
got the government [ __ ] oh but then
there seems to be a lot of joe biden hat
wares who want to tell people what to do
with their bars too oh wait but let's
talk about tiger specifically now the
tiger king is actually a maga supporter
isn't he yes
but he looks like one he didn't uh i
don't know do you think he still [ __ ]
with him profiling do you think uh the
tiger king still likes trump because he
didn't uh with him
he didn't get pardoned he had a whole
[ __ ] limo and everything tiger king
jokes alec is a really quote a really
big trump supporter right really big
trump backer it's us okay i think it's
one of those one-sided relationships
where
[ __ ] tiger king loves trump but trump
doesn't love him it sounds like a
one-sided relationship right
to that answer though i think that
anything should be
not anything animal wise
domesticated blah blah can be a pet as
long as it's not endangered joe exotic
also was disappointed he wasn't pardoned
by trump carol baskin says that she
loves donald trump as well so tiger
people
love
megan but they also own sanctuaries
they're not like
hobbyists yeah that's different like
being a hobbyist wild animal owner yeah
is that more this side or more this side
you guys think
a lobbyist
wild animal you guys you [ __ ] i
didn't hear that would you say
it depends because for me you could put
both of those together because corporate
democrats and corporate republicans are
those okay so they'll have sex so you're
telling me that this is actually not
this
but it's actually this yeah
and they just flip it around whenever
they want and then and then this why did
joe biden continue to trump policies
right why why did trump continue
obamacare
i think they like this too oh yeah
they're scissoring dude they're [ __ ]
they hate [ __ ] children
it's all combined
with michael myers yeah that's what it
ties it all in las vegas how can we look
so happy anthony oh no i'm just uh you
shut up
i like when anthony claps back at bart
yeah that's good
i like that tiger i like um exotic pets
like i think it's awesome i think okay i
feel like yeah i want to get a monkey
i'll have a monkey in vegas no way you
can't i was at a pet store i was at a
pet store in vegas this is like 2003 and
that's a long time
we were buying my sister a hedgehog we
crossed state lines from california into
nevada to purchase a hedgehog you
trafficked an illegal [ __ ] exotic
animal allegedly
i'm so proud of you steve oh thank you
we smuggled it good for you right that's
some virginia's [ __ ]
man we're trying we're we're right now
my family's white trash for sure so we
smuggled a hedgehog back into california
right for my sister as a pet but when we
were at at the store there's a monkey in
the cage he's going like
that like a little spider couldn't
believe what's going on
[Laughter]
i think he knew that i was kind of a
celebrity yeah
he's a cool [ __ ] that's steve green from
[ __ ] recorder he's a bank bus guy
he's the consensual guy
was the monkey for sale though yeah
he's like 5g dude
i want a monkey i feel like a monkey is
your animal bro like if you were to have
an exotic animal it would be a monkey or
something it's gotta be a baby
chimpanzee yeah and then we're in
diapers and [ __ ] yeah but if he becomes
too strong and big then i'm gonna have
to donate him to the zoo and he's going
to miss me and then not really be
associated with like the monkeys like so
like what do you call it like [ __ ] so
sociologized with the other monkeys and
[ __ ] so they'll be like
so so that's why you can't release them
in the wild right because like they're
like this fool's weird and [ __ ] if we
get to energize the school yeah and you
take them to the zoo it'll be even worse
because it's like this guy's weird
but i'm gonna do that to them so then
he'll look forward to my visits when i
come to the zoo and he goes oh please
take me back and i'm like no i can't
because you're too big now do you think
the monkey would resent you i don't
think they have i think his monkey would
wear a blue hat dude [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i want a drama teacher to
pass out what joe said as a monologue
for all the kids
you have to do
you have 45 you have 45 minutes to
prepare this monologue
and circle all the misspellings
what a challenge
i can't even repeat myself they're just
like uh what's this guy's motivation
we have no [ __ ] idea i don't know no
idea there's a lot of poor he jerks off
a lot uh
he says he says analogize or whatever
so analogize
thank you monkeys have to be
sociologized into the wild right okay
it's true it's a don king quote it's
like when you captivate a [ __ ] um
when you captivate yeah when you
captivate a dolphin right
and you want to rehabilitate it right
what ends up happening is like
yeah it it it's like let's say it's hurt
like it was caught on the fish nets and
[ __ ] so then you you [ __ ] um you know
you're talking about a water bottle nose
dolphin yeah and then you refurbish this
dolphin right you refurbish that
[ __ ]
refurbishing dolphins that's the next
[ __ ] dude it's a reefer that's the new
market yo you refurbish it that monkey
you saw that monkey on that it was a
refurbished [ __ ] monkey it's
refurbished and then um you know it's
repurposed you know because it's all
about sustainability and then you send
them you can't just set them back into
the wild because they'll be like who's
this [ __ ] you know they'll
they'll see that all of a sudden there's
some racialism exactly
unaccepted
they'll
they'll they'll [ __ ] be like yo
what's up with this fool's gender i i
don't know like who is this for i can't
even i don't even know what to make of
this dolphin
and then so that's why to protect them
they have to keep them at sea world
class we have some new pages
okay and actually get an extra 15
minutes
that's true yeah you'd have to keep
manchu that's part of the monologue yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you